well the Syrian people are no strangers
to Devastation and suffering of course
after an 11-year Civil War which has
left cities in ruin and hundreds of
thousands of people dead but that trauma
has now been compounded by the impact of
these earthquakes and a warning that
this report from our Middle East
correspondent Aleister bunkel includes
pictures of the rescue of a young baby
found next to the body of one of the
victims
this is why there is still some hope
a little girl called Noah is gently
pulled out from the remains of her home
in Northwest Syria The Rescuers
encourage her to talk to her father who
is standing nearby waiting to hug his
daughter
of course these moments of Hope are
vastly outnumbered by the discovery of
dead bodies they are finding more and
more every hour
I know
the Syrian white helmets are working
around the clock and with little
International Help
they must feel that the world has
forgotten about them but Aid agencies
haven't reached the area yet simply
because they just haven't been able to
negotiate away across the one border
crossing that is currently open
this is Aleppo before the war it used to
be Syria's commercial hub then it became
the center of intense fighting now it
looks like this the city is under Syrian
regime control and present Assad's
government has asked for international
Aid
a Russian cargo plane landed in Syria
today but after years of defying the
West Assad might now be forced to accept
their help
we need heavy equipment ambulances and
firefighting Vehicles we don't have fire
fighting vehicles to put out fires we
don't have heavy equipment to conduct
rescue operations there are a lot of
issues surfacing now due to the
sanctions sanctions against the Syrian
people
in another Syrian Town another moment of
relief at first this young child appears
to be lifeless
and then
[Music]
they carefully scrape away the rubble
and pull him free coughing from the dust
in his throat
the body of a woman lies next to the
baby
the difference between life and death
was only a matter of inches Aleister
bunkel Sky News